coming up coming off and sit down again
okay so thank you Rick thank you
everyone for coming so the topic for
debate is artificial intelligence we
appear to be reaching some kind of
cultural convergence or sort of zenith
of conversations at least in public
about what artificial intelligence is
and what it can do for us there have
been a spate of films over the last
couple of years some good some
absolutely terrible things like chappie
and Oh transcendence
age of Ultron ex machina so we've had a
range of views expressed by some not
insignificant public figures such as
Elon Musk and Stephen Hawking and Bill
Gates about the potential threats of
artificial intelligence expressed in
public so the questions that arise from
that are many and we didn't have that
long but we're going to attempt to
address some of them during that session
things like should we be concerned are
we heading for the singularity we'll be
talking about that will a eyes be
smarter faster and generally better than
us and therefore are we destined to be
subservient and possibly extinguished by
our non-human creations now we will be
taking questions at the ends they will
be roving mics on the floor so to come
with your questions and there are two
mics in there in the cheap seats in the
balcony so our panel we have some of the
finest human minds that are thinking
about these questions currently we have
so we're going to do this in order from
the far end Riva Melissa tez who is a a
transhumanist advocate founder of the
Berlin singularity group she's a tech
investment consultant and a writer on AI
next to her we have Marie Shanahan he's
a professor of cognitive robotics at
Imperial College London he's a sir
he was also a scientific adviser to the
recent AI phone ex machina which is in
my humble opinion the best AI phone that
has been yet made
not least because I was also the
scientific adviser for it next to him we
have Nick Bostrom he's the author of
super intelligence groundbreaking sort
of alarm bell book on artificial
intelligence a professor of philosophy
at Oxford and to my immediate left we
have Dan glazier who's a neuroscientist
and director of the Science Gallery at
King's College in London so I think to
start off with we need to get a couple
of definitions out of the way I
described you River as a transhumanism
advocates briefly what is transhumanism
so I think the first thing is that
transhumanism isn't as well as it sounds
and and Nick is one of the founding
fathers of this this idea that it's the
idea that we have technology we have the
capabilities to advance Humanity in a
way that's not previously been
established or there's things like super
health super longevity living for a long
time as healthy as possible and the
extension of healthy life and super
happiness and the abolishment of
suffering and basically all the things
that humanity has aspired for since you
know I say in America since the founding
fathers it sounds weird now to say
transhumanism but it should be the goals
of humanity to live longer and extend it
and expand it so it's just the idea of
using technology to do that okay now
when we talk about artificial
intelligence when we talk about
consciousness these are best fuzzy
concepts when we're talking about humans
when we're talking about biology when
we're talking about AI in terms of in
terms of robotics the types of things
that you guys do Marie what what do we
mean what is artificial intelligence
what is the scope of the definition well
I think first of all we have to
distinguish between different senses of
the word artificial intelligence so we
have to distinguish between the kind of
AI technology there's actually around us
today and that might unfold over the
next five years or so and the kind of
thing we see in the movies human-level
AI so these are different kinds of
things so the kind of thing that we have
around us today is basically the kind of
technology that carries out tasks that
we think of us as needing
when they're carried out by humans or
carries out some aspect to such tasks so
we see examples in in personal
assistance like Apple Siri or Google now
Cortana self-driving cars are a great
example a slightly scary example is the
potential of autonomous weapons and
other examples are the use of machine
learning technology with big data to try
and understand better the buying habits
and behavior of people based on the
large amounts of data about them so
those kinds of technologies are becoming
very prominent there's a lot of
excitement about that kind of technology
and a lot of investment in those sorts
of areas and we're no doubt going to see
a lot of impact on our economy and
society from that kind of technology in
the not-too-distant future now in the
more distant future maybe will one day
achieve human-level artificial
intelligence and what I mean by that or
to distinguish that from the first kind
of AI the first kind of AI is very
specialist it can only do one particular
task typically where as humans are
capable of doing an enormous variety of
tasks and and and learning new ones and
indeed inventing the whole new kinds of
tasks so a human level AI will be able
to match humans in that kind of way it
will be a general generalist human-level
AI is is general intelligence and we
really have no idea quite how to produce
that kind of AI yet this is something
that we see in science-fiction films I
suspect we may well manage it by the end
of this century but as yet we really
don't know how to do it there are
conceptual breakthroughs that are
probably needed before we get there when
we do get there then really all bets are
off about how much impact that will have
on society society and that's a very
interesting question to think about
which Nick has been talking about in
fact I want to come on to it too what's
going to happen in the future in just a
minute with Nick but I just want to turn
to down because you were talking about
human level intelligence and human level
consciousness as being something which
is in the not immediate but possible
future Daniel ah you're a biologist you
deal with with real biological entities
in the human brain
what can
ai researchers learn from how we
understand they have a human brain works
well I think the first thing to say is
that in a sense Europe biology and
artificial intelligence are in the
similar situation of being completely
lost at the moment so although there's
huge amounts of investment in
neuroscience both in the US with a big
brain project and in Europe what we're
doing is gathering huge amounts of data
but the domain is pretty much a
theoretical which is to say that nobody
has any idea what's actually going on
very basic things like sleep
like memory like how anesthetics work we
have actually no theories about what's
going on there and so the amassing of
data about real brains is analogous it
seems to me to this huge Moore's Law
driven application of computing power to
AI but without any real sense of what
might be happening what the algorithms
that are going to give rise to the big
breakthroughs are and I have it I mean
I'm pleased to say that I'm not the
first person sitting on this stage today
to advocate this but it does seem to me
that the problem with the problems we're
looking at is that they're pretty male
and also they've forgotten about
children so if for years chess was
considered to be the most intelligent
thing you could do and we solved that we
solved it basically by doing exhaustive
search or closed to we just look to all
the possible moves and eventually when
the computer became fast enough to look
forward far enough to outwit the
Grandmaster then it could beat the
Grandmaster of chess but computers are
still stupid and in fact the things that
computers find easiest to do are the
things that we learn as adults and the
thing that men the things that men are
good at warfare in running corporations
planning transport systems what they're
not good as the things that children are
good at so generating learning
environments there's a very famous
experiment with mothers and daughters
it's called the tongue protrusion test
and there was an original theory that
babies were mirroring their mother's
gestures very early on as early as a few
weeks why because when mommy sticks her
tongue out the baby stick their tongue
out to and everyone says that that's
mirroring very early it turns out that
the kid is not mirroring the mother
because if the mother goes then the kid
sticks his tongue out so what it's doing
is expressing its excitement of being
stimulated by sticking its tongue out
and the mother miss reads that as
mirroring and therefore spends lots of
time nurture
the child and babies are very good
mechanisms for generating learning
environments from the people around them
it comes as earlier older children with
the Y question so what we do I so what
we need to become better at is
understanding these very basic things
how do we generate a learning
environment and how do we understand
better what other people are thinking
and when we get these mind-reading
techniques better we'll be able to have
artificial intelligence on a firmer
footing and not just go straight for the
grown up male stuff last point what is
it that women are better at than men I
mean men are better at chess perhaps
perhaps their veteran being CEOs of tech
companies there's a very interesting
study from Anita Woolley and colleagues
that was written up quite recently if
you do the IQ test on individuals okay
you get a score what happens if you do
the IQ test on groups so you form a
group of people and you get them to
solve an IQ test together okay what is
the quality of the group that makes it
as a group most intelligent what they
all need to be good at is by reading by
reading is knowing what's going on in
people's minds by looking at their eyes
that's getting mental states and
inferring them from their actions women
are much better at that than men and the
principle thing you can do if you want a
group to act intelligent is to fill it
with women actually the most direct
correlation on the study from literally
in colleagues is not to merge the IQ
test of a group the biggest predictor is
not the IQs of the individuals that the
proportion of women in that group when
you start to understand that the
intelligence and the brain power that
women deploy every day is something that
we should be trying to model and and and
drive from an artificial point of view I
think we're more likely to make progress
I'm I'm choosing to ignore the comment
about CEOs of tech companies perhaps you
can you can beat Dan up later this I
guess is directed to Murray and Reva but
in terms of looking at how human
intelligence works and the types of
models that psychologists and
neuroscientists look at trying to
understand the human brain and human
behavior is this the type of thing that
AI researchers are modeling or should be
modeling rebirth well oh well we were
just talking about this about two
minutes ago and the energy they have
around neuroscience and in related in
relation to AI is that when we try to
build planes we kind of looked at birds
and we've got these kind of like weird
flapping things and then we built a
principle of what flight should be and
then we managed to conquer what a plane
should be and I kind of think the same I
mean I think the understanding of
mapping the brain is a very valuable
thing but the non domain-specific
principle of intelligence hasn't quite
been conquered yet and if we can find
something that's not neuro specific I
mean we're we're all so different in our
you know neuro makeup and the way that
is being done is we're following such
traditional recipes were looking at the
brain we're looking at like deep
learning or reinforcement learning plus
some part of brain and I think I agree
with Marion and smoky bone panel but it
might be some real outlier view that
actually cracks AI because it's not it's
not like anything that's ever been done
before we don't have a true definition
intelligences but do we have enough of
an understanding human consciousness to
even model it's in experimental
circumstances let alone create
artificial versions I think we should we
should be very clear about
distinguishing between consciousness and
intelligence because they're not the
same thing we can easily imagine
building an artifact which is it can
behave in a very intelligent way and
perhaps doesn't have consciousness and
conversely we we have plenty of
conscious creatures in the world who are
certainly unconscious and capable of
suffering for example but not
necessarily that intelligent compared to
humans so they're very different things
but if I could just respond to John's
earlier remarks it certainly I think
you're absolutely right and agree with
everything you said
but in defensive of a I should point out
that it's a vast subfield of artificial
intelligence there's epigenetic robotics
with developmental robotics is it
so-called there's effective computing
which which looks at these kinds of
topics as well so it's a so it's
certainly a perspective which is very
much adopted by a great many AI
researchers it's quite fashionable at
the moment and there are lots of people
my old friend geoff hinton you know
being acquired by google there's lots of
money coming in but i think that there's
a worry that the tech crisis about
gender balance may superimpose itself
onto the AI problem it feels to me as if
they're addressing the wrong problems
and in a sense the tech you know the
Silicon Valley product has been selling
us problems solutions to problems that
most of us don't have like how to do
sociability without eye contact there
are quite a lot of men who have problems
with that but it's not a general problem
and the solutions which people are
coming up with are that and they're
selling us to a problems which most of
us I think don't generally have Nick
Mary talked about the immediate future
but also the long-term future your your
book is largely about what possibly
could happen and the things that people
like Elon Musk and Stephen Hawking have
been worried about in public what do you
think is going to happen I think that AI
will gradually a growing capabilities
perhaps slowly and incrementally
at first and perhaps for a long time but
at some point we will figure out the
basic algorithms that generate general
intelligence in humans the same powerful
learning algorithms that enable us to
learn not just one job but any job the
same powerful planning algorithms that
make it possible for us to tackle like
almost universal set of problems so once
we have that sorted out I think then we
will have machines that are human level
general intelligent and quite techno
stake as to how far we are from that
point that in fact I think nobody really
has any good evidence for predicting
that this will or will not happen by any
very specific date we did a survey of
some of the world's leading AI experts
two years ago and one
the questions we ask fear was by what
year do you think there's a 50%
probability that we will have human
level machine intolerance and the medium
answer to that was 2040 or 2050
depending on precise to which group but
with the large uncertainty on either
side it could happen much sooner or much
later but if and when we do reach that
point I think we will soon thereafter
have super intelligence machines that oh
not just slightly better at us at some
tasks but that radically outperform us
across all complex intellectual domains
much like we outperform the chimpanzees
or like the rabbits and so with that
kind of enormous intelligence comes the
potential for enormous power with that
intelligence you could reach
technological maturity quickly doing the
inventing and the science on digital
timescales and so this transition to the
machine in Havana Sarah I think has the
potential to be a pivotal moment in
human history perhaps the most important
event that will ever have happened on
this planet and the ultimate outcome
might depend in some scenarios quite
sensitively on the precise initial
conditions the exact design of the first
entity that achieves the super
intelligence do you think it is the
accumulation I mean you sort of alluded
to it just a minute ago but is it is it
RIBA talks about how how you know we can
build a is a very good at chess but the
transferable learning and deep learning
is not something that they really
capable at the moment is the main
barrier that we need to accumulate
various skills and variants intelligent
behaviors into one entity i I think it's
more likely that there is one or a small
number of fundamental tricks that maybe
you need to flesh out with a lot of
details but a relatively limited set of
basic mechanisms that generate
intelligence in humans a I used to be
back in the 50s and 60s and 70s really
about programmers putting commands in a
box as you would hard code the facts or
features and then yeah I could perform
some simple inferences on that and these
systems were useful for some limited
purposes but they didn't scale they were
brittle if you put in one wrong thing
the whole thing just turned out nonsense
but today I
really much more about learning it's
about designing algorithms and
computation architectures that from raw
perceptual data like just pixels on the
screen let us say a large data set can
themselves figure out what the relevant
features are built out concepts complex
representations and learn to detect
patterns in this and I think it's this
kind of learning I I that is most likely
to eventually reach human all feels very
much to me as if you're attacking the
problem at the wrong end because it's
not it doesn't seem to me plausible
either that there are a small number of
simple algorithms which if we find them
we'll get intelligence all that what we
need to do is have more and more
powerful systems to do it I mean one of
the really striking things about humans
more than chimpanzees is how helpless we
are for so long
after we're born and it seems to me that
the reason for that is because we are
constructing the architecture of the
machine if you want to call it a machine
through experience the idea that you
have a big purpose you know
off-the-shelf computing machine with
huge amounts of bits and bytes and lots
of inputs and that will run an algorithm
makes intelligent is fanciful we need
basic experience we need to build it
from the bottom up in terms of learning
and it's this helplessness in the face
of the world which we need to study
first once we've understood how that
gives rise to the thinking machine then
we can look at the algorithms that
impinge briefly it's like you're
agreeing so the basic idea with the
learning algorithm is that it starts out
helpless and then after you learn you
become competent just like a human child
us so you don't start out with all of
these skills there but you start out
with the ability to acquire those skills
that's what learning is in terms of
what's a I researchers are doing
currently Murray this is a question for
you they seem to be very focused on
individual tasks so we you know we're a
long way from what both Dan is talking
about in the biological context and what
Nick is talking about in a you know
broader context but what sort of things
let's talk about the positives about
current AI before we talk about it's our
exact existential threats well of course
a lot of AI researchers at the moment
are interested in in the kinds of
short-term immediate applications of the
sort of technology that I was that I was
describing especially because there's a
lot of investment interest in that
at the moment so there's a lot of
incentive to look at that stuff but if
you look at the people who who are
interested in artificial general
intelligence or human human level AI as
a longer-term goal then I think pretty
much all of them would agree very much
for that perspective that it's all about
doing things from a bottom-up learning
things from scratch without building in
anything in advance about what all very
little about what the world is like out
there and if we look for example at
google deepmind 2a1
little company who certainly have that
as a named and that's very much their
their philosophy their interested in
learning everything from scratch without
building anything into their systems
about what kind of world they're going
to learn about at the moment they're
still looking at some what toy examples
but if you take that into a into a the
kind of domain that a human child or an
or a young animal has to deal with and I
think that's the right the right kind of
approach okay I think we've pretty much
sorted this entire field out in 20
minutes that we've had but if there are
any questions stick your hand up and a
microphone will come to you if you're on
this floor so I can see there's one
there if you're in the balcony then go
to the microphone let's let's take a
couple of questions and then I want to
just briefly ask the whole panel about
existential threats as is the title
either David Bennigsen from a company
big data company called signal I just
wanted to know what you guys thought
about the role their ethics plays in all
of this obviously mmm you're talking
about such a major impact that this
technology in this field can have on the
world and I I know that deep mind
incorporated an ethics board into their
into their company after they were
required I just wanted to hear a little
bit about your thoughts on that who
wants to have a go at ethics because
that's a really easy subject Rico I mean
I'm just going to say the the three of
us for sure and there was a big a is
safety conference at beginning this year
ai safety has become one of the most
prominent areas of AI research I think
right now it's the we're thinking about
ethics and more than we are thinking
about the first principles of building
it I think
I think there's Nick has done an amazing
job at bringing attention to that and
definitely with the guise of deep mind
and etc so I think that I don't know I
think that ethics is probably the
biggest one of the biggest areas of AI
research right now if not even maybe too
much and it's it's it's the it's
probably the most written about thing
right now in terms of AI not about
whether or not it's being done is it
it's fabulous that we're thinking about
this now it's I mean this is early doors
for talking about morality and ethics
for things that haven't really been well
they've been conceived but were a long
way from actually building I would say
that I think the ethical issues look
very different depending on whether
we're looking at near-term incremental
capabilities in which case the ethical
questions are a kind of continuous with
other ethical questions in new
technologies and drones you know be
anonymous privacy all of these kind of
things so these are legitimate and
worthwhile customs to think about and to
debate but I think the questions that
arise if and when we get machines that
achieve the same general intelligence as
humans have are very different and quite
unique it's entirely new kinds of
ethical questions that arise there and
also questions of even if you had some
views about what the ethics should be
like what kind of outcomes would be
desirable also big major research
questions in how you would actually
implement that in machine how you would
create a machine that could learn what
human intentions are that could learn
what ethics is and then actually be
motivated to pursue those those values
that's a big new open research area that
I think is going to turn out to be very
important okay there was another
question on this side I think someone's
got the mic right the very back okay
question there's a comment brief if you
will yep there's a guy called yo Wilson
long dead sociologist I thought what's a
CEO something rather in the 1950s I
think he said we have Paleolithic
emotions medieval institutions and the
technology of the gods
and it doesn't seem to me that much has
changed since then and that it maybe
just speak to down a great point about
maybe the AI you're talking about fills
the gap of the medieval institution
and their inefficiencies but does it
address the fact that correlation is not
the same as understanding I don't think
yeah Wilson is dead actually thank you
though it's a sign of his significance
in culture that yes it's very old if I
could adjust the two points together I
think that retrofitting ethics or having
an ethics committee on the side is doing
the whole thing exactly back to front
one of the things that children learn
early on is how they ought to behave and
I'm not going to go Freudian but this
development of a supervisory in of a
super-ego what they should or shouldn't
do is critical to the development of an
intelligent human and it feels to me as
if and this is why I'm at Science
Gallery in London that you've got to
bring in non scientific domains you've
got to bring in fact non experts into
the conversation not only because
there's a democratic deficit and not
only because this stuff is too important
to be left of a scientist and the
technologists but because the answers to
the important questions about why we're
intelligent and how to make machines
more intelligent will arise in
situations where we can speak to the
arts where we can involve young people
in decisions when we can have proper
interdisciplinary conversations so we
need more spaces like that and less of
the kind of algorithm bashing and
theoretical stuff although that's
important it needs to be embedded you
know you know in a proper view of human
culture okay we've got one minute left
so it needs to be an incredibly facile
quick answer to the question and I want
to go down the panel starting with Reva
does artificial intelligence pose an
existential threat to humankind
you have 25 seconds yes maybe no
probably well but also an existential
hope at the same time yes yes I can't
resist the gag so AI as you meant many
of you know in the world if you google
it has two different significance as one
is artificial intelligence and the other
is artificial insemination and I just
have to say that in both cases and more
in favor of the natural kind
all right well that's as I say I don't
think we've really sorted that whole
issue out so well you guys can just stop
working in retirement from now on Sophie
could just I could just thank the panel
Dan blazer Nick Bostrom Mary Shanahan
and Reed Melissa tears thank you very
much
[Applause]